where you work the wav at NP how much
did we drink just a little bit just like
two years you had more than that no well
you're not even close to Union and you
how did you get here what town are you
in right now what do you mean where are
you right now kennworth okay so how'd
you get to kennworth I took the parkway
the parkway you came from this way
though yeah I I took the Parkway
off I took the Parkway and I took off of
the
Parkway and I was going to go on
she cuz I think you are that be more
than two beers
right I now it's three let's just
honesty is going to work with you be
honest honest with you I took a few
beers a few what's a few I have NOA give
me a fa just lean up against your car
for me okay you see your tire right yeah
did you know you hit that car on Cross
cross street why'd you run cuz you've
been drink you didn't you didn't run you
hit the car all the way over there and
you ended up over here I was just trying
like go home you trying to go home I was
just trying to pull over cuz you know
you had a little bit too much to drink
just a little bit okay what's your name
Gabby okay I'm
Travis Yankee 54 kilo Tango Charlie
Yankee 54 kilo Tango
Charlie
stay by your car okay hey
Rob hey
Rob Rob take a ride huh take a
ride follow the the trail see what she
hit where'd you come out of what where'd
you come out of um I just came from down
where you headed home where's Home Union
Union yeah where down your Shore where
didd you come from um Neptune I I work
in
Neptune where you work the W at neptun
how much did we drank just a little bit
just like two years you had more than
that no well you're not even close to
Union and you how did you get here what
town are you in right now what do you
mean but where are you right now
Kenworth okay so how'd you get to
kennworth I took the parkway the parkway
you came from this way though yeah I I
took the Parkway
off I took the Parkway and I took off of
the
Parkway and I was going to
go all right re
see see if we get that
information all right so this is what
we're going to do right now okay yeah I
can smell the alcohol you hit a park car
all the way over there and you were
trying to run okay I'm going to put you
through a couple fueld sobriety tests
okay cuz I think you are that be more
than two beers
right now it's three let's just honestly
is going to work with you be honest
honest with you I took a few beers a few
what's a few I don't know all right me
here just lean up against your car for
me
okay
who's the car registered to what who's
the car registered to
okay
okay you see your tire right yeah did
you know you hit that car on cross
street why' you run cuz you've been
drink you didn't you didn't run you hit
the car all the way over there and you
ended up over here I was just trying to
like go home you trying to go home I was
just trying to pull over cuz you know
you had a little bit too much to drink
just a little bit okay what's your name
okay I'm Travis okay this is what we're
going to do I have three different tests
I have to run on you okay for real soety
first one is called horizontal gaze the
Stag Mist I'm checking the involuntary
jerking of your eyes what you're going
to do stand up straight for me okay you
see this what color is it blue perfect
with your eyes and your eyes only you're
going to follow the tip of my pen okay
don't move your head I got you just your
eyeballs
okay just your eyeballs okay I got you
so don't move your head okay how old are
you uh 26
perfect
my contact we're almost done come on my
contact blurry got I got
you wait one more ready
okay
okay you feel comfortable walking in
those shoes yeah okay want you do you're
going to stand right here for me
okay face me you kind you can kind of
use this line oh perfect it's perfect
right what you're going to do okay this
is the walk and turn test okay okay what
I want you to do right now is stand with
your right foot in front of your left
with your heel touching your toe arms
down to your side I want you to stay in
that position while I explain the
instructions to you I'm also going to
demonstrate for you okay what you're
going to do is you're going to take nine
steps Heel To Toe Counting hang out loud
for me 1 2 3 4 and so on all the way up
until nine okay and now last step after
you take nine you're going to take small
steps to your left and come back nine
steps I'm going to demonstrate okay wait
I'm going to demonstrate for you okay
keep arms down to your side okay so I'm
going to take three steps but you're
going to take nine okay so look
something just like this okay and it's
going to be one two three on that last
step you're just going to turn kind of
like a pivot step but choppy steps just
like this and come back nine steps one
two three no I took three steps you're
going to take nine okay okay nine steps
Heel To Toe last step turn around and
come back nine steps okay count out loud
for me go ahead and begin
one I looking for the test stop counting
took more
steps
canot loud for me come
on okay the last one is called the
one-legged stand test okay any
injuries well I have arthritis where uh
in my ankles which one both of them both
of them but they're fine you're able to
walk and run and do exercises and all
kinds of stuff I mean yeah kind of okay
four can I just get the that's why my
balance is all types of fucked up okay
why I think your balance is all types
and messed up for other reasons right
now okay this is a little more of a
level surface there a little line there
okay so stand over here for me Dash what
I want you to do any leg of you're
choosing you're going to keep one on the
ground and when I tell you to so just
stand like this for me okay got you're
going to raise one foot approximately
six in off the ground okay looking at
the tip of your toe you're going to
count 1 1,000 2 1,000 3 1,000 until I
tell you to stop okay it's going to be
just like
this 1 1,000 2 1 1,000 3 1,000 4 1,000 5
1,000 until I tell you to stop okay
don't begin until I tell you to okay
okay all
right all right you ready yeah go ahead
and
begin I can't keep
going keep going stop for
balance arms down to your
side all right do me a favor yeah turn
around for
back you were under arrest for driving
while intoxicated
okay
53 I'm going to need a toe one under 450
[Applause]
stay right there for a second
okay TR I'll swing back around have a
seat only one car was
damaged get in there we go I'll crack
the window for you so I get some air
okay sit back sit back look up just put
your seat belt down okay
okay where's your purse and everything
everything's in my car okay
yeah you're all right all right c i
alert keywords alert DMV
record NC
alert alert
[Applause]
[Music]
DM we're going to turn the car
off get her Pur and
everything
is there
any booze in the car where's the
keys number on that car did she whose
car is it uh somebody
141 bu
he where the fuck are the keys
where's going home take that there
wallet in
there did you
really all
right there phone in
there
she said she's coming from
Neptune Neptune what is
this oh this is one of
those fake get the
yeti
yeah
legal that's
fine I just want to get her phone I want
to see if we can find a oh grab her
purse I got her purse the full
purse let's hope our machine's working
20 bucks is
not what else you need out of your car
just my phone where is that at I think
it's in the front seat in the there's a
lot in the front seat what do you mean
there a bunch of stuff there it's on tan
lotion all kind stuff where do you work
uh Neptune what's the name of the place
the Waverly at Neptune is it a bar no
what is it it's an apartment community
apartment community what do you do there
I'm theing consultant okay where were
you drinking um Headliners
headliners
all right then a getting it what do you
got there
Rob
huh is
it generic for what doesn't
say I'm going to say he's bir control
take one t of my mouth every day in the
morning probably yeah it's no generic
my zero refills though 90 pills that
would to be that H maybe 3 month supply
set our phones in the front
seat
she was a
headliner huh she said she worked at a I
can't find her
phone yeah that's it we need her
insurance here's the
insurance
really yeah
what 521
right I don't see a
phone
huh you can't open the front door you
can try I I couldn't get
itas
yeah it was bad it was
bad any idea where your phone is in the
front seat cuz we can't find it it might
be in myet
it should be there okay what kind of
phone is it uh iPhone iPhone yeah color
case or anything just
black
okay the black iPhone yeah
dark
I'm not worried about it but I just for
phone numbers for someone to come get
her ask her what her number is just go
Um uh the way she's acting very
flutatious not doing it okay never mind
wear
69 is it in the back
seat you checking this B yes it's
makeup
oh
well ask if she knows her parents
numbers by other
there who's the car seat for my daughter
you have a daughter yeah I know I fucked
up so how old your daughter she's F
almost five almost five yeah what if she
was in the car I I would never drive
with her in the car no never she never
drive drunk right I would never drive
drunk car shouldn't drive drunk at all
right cuz what
happens I'm we can't find fucking idiot
we can't find your phone do you know
like uh a phone number of somebody who
would pick you up in like a couple hours
unfortunately you do know you know Fun
by heart yeah all right perfect who are
you going to call to pick you up wait it
might be on the floor though we there's
a lot of stuff on the floor up your
front seat no I mean like on the front
cuz when I like jumped out yeah I like
jumped
out it under her
seat
got it no oh
well all you want to wait for Saro yeah
I'm going to bring her back and start
doing all those
non
huh I got they're right here probably a
good
idea here you
go right there you got the wallet and
everything yeah I can use
that good got it all
right no we didn't not find it Lu my
part we're going to bring you to
headquarters now my partner is going to
wait here for uh the tow truck
okay
yeah by
three go
ahead four is going to remain unseen and
wait for us to Sparrow I'll be
transporting one female to
headquarters 107
64.1 107 64.1
receive
3 Insurance C is with the
purse
for
who do you live
with your
parents you have anything in your
pockets or anything like that all right
my uh my other partner's in here she's
working with that she's a female um
she's going to just give you a oh she's
gone make sure you're not carrying
anything or anything like that on
you arriving headquarters 107 64.5 107
64.5